[Musik]
und warum mussten
dort probte und versucht ihr spaß hier
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
sanieren
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
sanieren und alaska
heute zeigen wir euch wie smarties
mappings hausgemacht leicht geben wir
haben 50 g butter 100 gramm zucker eine
prise salz 1 teelöffel familie extra
zweier diesen innenraumtemperatur 180
gramm mehl 1 2 teelöffel natron 50 gramm
butter milch ist auch in contemporary 20
gramm cacau 50 gramm butter milch ist
auch in raumtemperatur also m
die muffins und dessen mama muffins und
das einfach mehr show klasse drauf und
deswegen kann geht's mit dem weißen zeit
an
die muss auch gleich sein
25 ich weiß selber inhalte schon sehr
dahin gemacht ja ja sag das mal rein
wir haben jetzt rein gemacht und die
prise salz
danach kommt die butter rein nein danke
nach bissen an den extrakt kein aber du
bist
[Musik]
einfach so
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir die trockenen zutaten
also mehr und so weiter im lazarett im
kakao mit sam mit buttermilch und ich
hab grad
die anpassung buttermilch mit mehl
eigentliche reingemacht
jetzt schon mal hier was freilich auch
dann treu zum drittel ungefähr weiß ja
also ungefähr die hälfte beim kit ein
drittel heißt ja dass man es durch drei
teilen
das heißt ich mache mir hier so eine
linie hier und hier
und alles was zählt drin ist das hier
das dritte hier bauen das dritte war ja
noch kaputter zug kommt und dann ist es
später ungefähr die hälfte kommt ja noch
jetzt stell dich mal den hellen kurz zur
seite
er sieht irgendwie wie wackelpudding aus
ich habe jetzt den kakao mit der
buttermilch und mit dem tag zusammen
gemacht und es wäre ich jetzt
[Musik]
freilich macht er ist ein gut zwei
jahren zu gehen so mache ich nicht ganz
so voll war eigentlich nur 2 klar
gemacht wer nachlässig sind
hast du mal du musst man dem einen frei
machen ich mache von gm heides rein
ok also haben wir machen das jetzt
abwechselnd kassenchefs hier ein halbes
nehme teil des jahres in größer ist und
als kleiner und deswegen macht sie von
dem ranzen und ich von dem rasen steht
der name kuchen
codemasters war das beste nämlich den
ein anschlag auf alle aufteilen würden
ja nochmal was ist los
[Musik]
mama macht mich alles wird wohl um
nachschub fehlt eigentlich auch ein tag
ohne eier gehen jetzt gemeinsam
übernehmen
und das ist gar keine eier rainer laib
hier fehlt noch bis um eine kleine gabe
ich zeig dir vertritt
seit montag müssen dass man den nama
effekt infekt muss man einfach gabel
nehmen und ihn drinnen nur einmal drin
er ist das ein kleiner mama effekt
finden
[Musik]
er war lecker können sie so lange auf
rollen und jetzt sind sie genau das was
noch übrig ist das sind nicht weg
gemacht habt dann könnt ihr diese
streichen und die smarties braucht
dekorieren okay und ich mache so lange
unsere mittagessen jetzt schokolade
doppelpass mit dem zu heilig jetzt von
tier halten dass man es auch noch 47
jetzt könnt ihr das verstreichen der
gramm was man den schlüssel an
jetzt geht's wieder okay aber gerade
eben war die schüssel zu heiß hier das
darfst du jetzt machen hier und da etwas
machen am gestreift
[Musik]
bis der schokolade schmeckt verbessern
fuchs hatte mit soviel kannst du hier
drauf machen was ist der papa
unromantisch norma ist auch eine
typische ein typischer schwabe und
unromantisch okay
[Musik]
und da kannst du noch ein bisschen drauf
machen
in der mitte besucht
[Musik]
die ärmel sind nicht das problem
komm ich mache ja noch ein bisschen
drauf und dann könnt ihr die smarties
drauflegen macht ihr das ja so wie auf
dem bild habe probiert mal wieder auf
dem bild l mal auf dem feld da ist
einfach sonders smarties blume macht ihr
so eine smarties blumen zeigt mir dass
überall schokolade darf ich probieren
aber ist ja noch nicht fertig
normalerweise müssen uns jetzt natürlich
noch trocknen lassen habe ich denn
probieren oder den nicht mit dem hat den
x teilen
achtung ich gebe euch auch ein bisschen
ich probiere mal vom kuchen
magst du beißen
november entdeckt noch schön von gut
gemacht obwohl es auch beißen richtig
lecker und die zubereitung war ganz
einfach oder mu und wo gibt es das
rezept ella
you can also falls ihr lust habt acht zu
machen
schaut auf seine sap vorbei ist doch
dein video nicht fertig moderieren ist
nicht mein video teaser video sagten
abschluss
1 kommentar unter youtube schreibt sie
in die kommentare seien aber erinnerte
kann schon nicht sagen die leute
brauchen keinen kopf hoch sie wissen
vielleicht nicht wie das funktioniert
aber dann können sie in der app
nachschauen und technik ok
[Musik]